[Music]
good morning John it's Monday March 12th
I have something I need to show you
that's awesome
freaking awesome thanks go to Laila of
bookshelves of doom voxcom
you can go there and buy amazing shirts
from her to support her book habit not
sure if you can get this shirt I think I
might just be exclusive to members of
the actual Brotherhood for not it like
averse to having honorary members of the
Brotherhood there is sort of Hank and
John we get perks don't be my hands are
today might be a little bit of a dry
episode because I have to teach John how
to make a podcast because I can't
obviously do it with his video so he has
to do it too and I can't send them a
text-based tutorial which would be
frankly much easier so I'm gonna have to
do it in a video blog form yeah I'm
doing a podcast on how to make podcasts
if you're not interested in making
podcasts this might not be your favorite
episode of motherhood 2.0 however I will
be throwing in some juicy bits and you
will definitely want to be around for
those so that further adue podcasting
first step download fetch fetch is an
FTP program for Macintosh if you don't
have a Macintosh download smart FTP you
can download them both in all kinds of
places but I usually use download comm
because it is extraordinarily easy to
remember thank you for downloading fetch
5.1 at download comm oh my goodness
gracious that's pretty cool
so we're going to use fetch to get into
our FTP server and then upload something
what's something you ask well of course
our mp4 files which we are uploading
every weekday anyways to YouTube it's
important to note here for people who
aren't my brother that you can't have a
podcast if you don't have web hosting
Brotherhood to comm is hosted at
bluehost.com i also host stuff at a and
hosting and midphase all very good web
hosting companies that i would suggest
that just finished downloading and i'm
opening it so we have now installed
such-and-such wants to know what the
host name is I might think it would be
FTP Brotherhood to come but it's not the
host name is
ringg words org ftp Greenwoods org the
username is GRE and wor the password is
the lake where the cabin was followed by
the first four digits of our old address
in Orlando blue into the public HTML
folder and then go into the Brotherhood
2 folder but now that you've logged in
to the Brotherhood 2 directory you will
find a podcast directory so basically
just drag it on over the great news is
that you can upload all of your videos
just by clicking and dragging and then
dragging all of them over and go get
lunch or something because it's going to
take several hours because we have a lot
of videos already now John once you done
a pull in all the files you have to go
to podcast blaster comm then go to the
podcast syndication tool sign in using
my email address and the password that
we've had since we were like babies I
think you know which one I'm talking
about you go in there and then you say
create a new podcast then you can fill
in all the data including most
importantly the URL of the place where
the file is now so if you've uploaded
into the broadcast director of brother
who to comm it will be HTTP colon slash
slash wwe.com swash podcasts slash March
8th dot mp4 or whatever it is and you
push publish and you have published that
podcast to our podcast RSS feed then we
just have to publish that RSS feed for
everybody to find we will have a podcast
and people who can't get youtube but
their work will be able to watch our
videos woo I promised you juicy bits
this is a gigantic picture of me as a
baby baby I'm really curly hair and I'm
gonna Mickey Mouse shirt I am Hank I'm a
giant baby we're gonna miss you say
juicy bits number 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 you can find it myspace.com by
clicking on our pictures Katherine and I
did some scanning this weekend hmm I'll
see you and hopefully your podcasts in
the podcast directory tomorrow